Aquí he dibujado la parábola clásica
"y" igual a "x" cuadrada y lo que quiero hacer es pensar cómo puedo hacerle para desplazar esta parábola,
así que pensemos en unos cuantos ejemplos.
Primero pensemos en la gráfica de la curva esta es "y" igual a "x" cuadrada,
ahora pensemos cómo se vería la gráfica de "y" - "k" igual a
"x" cuadrada ¿Cómo se vería eso?
Bien por aquí vemos cuando "x" es igual a 0 "x" cuadrada también es igual a 0
esta es esta curva amarilla,
así que "x" cuadrada es igual a "y" o "y" es igual a "x" cuadrada pero, para esta "x" cuadrada no es igual a "y",
es más bien igual a "y" -"k" entonces
cuando "x" es 0 y lo elevamos al cuadrado, 0 al cuadrado no nos da "y", nos da "y" -"k".
así que esto va a ser "k" veces menor que "y".
Otra forma de pensarlo es que esto es 0 y si es "k" veces menor que "y"
entonces "y" debe estar en "k" donde sea que "k" esté. Así que "Y" debe estar en "k"
justo ahí.
Así que por lo menos para este punto tuvo el efecto de desplazarse hacia arriba, la "y" el valor de "y"
"k" unidades y de hecho esto será cierto para cualquiera de estos valores.
Entonces piensen "x" estando aquí para esta curva amarilla si elevan al cuadrado este valor de "x"
obtenemos este valor de "y" y claramente
no está dibujado a escala pero, si lo eleva en este valor de "x" lo lleva ahí
pero, ahora para esta curva justo aquí
"x" cuadrada no la corta solo lo lleva a "y" -"k" así que la "k" debe ser o la "y"
debe estar "k" veces  más arriba que esto, así que esto es
"y" -k, "y" debe estar "k" veces más arriba que esto, la "y" debe estar aquí.
Entonces vemos que esta curva es esencialmente la curva azul pero, desplazada "k" unidades  hacia arriba
desplazada hacia arriba, así que haciéndola
"y"- k es igual a "x" cuadrada pero, desplazada hacia arriba, "k" unidades
cualquier valor que tengamos está desplazado "k" veces hacia arriba así que esta distancia es una constante.
Es una constante "k" la distancia vertical entre estas 2 parábolas.
Ahora trataré de dibujar esto limpiamente,
lo más limpio que pueda. Esta distancia vertical es una constante "k", ahora pensemos en cómo
desplazarla horizontalmente.
Pensemos qué pasaría si yo dijera que "y" es igual a algo diferente a "x" cuadrada
x - h, x -h al cuadrado
pensemos en eso, este es el valor que obtenemos de "y"
cuando solo elevamos al cuadrado el 0, obtenemos "y" igual a cero pero ¿Cómo obtenemos
"y" igual a 0 aquí? Esta cantidad tendrá que ser 0 entonces,
"x" - "h" tendrá que ser 0 o "x" tendrá que ser igual a "h".
Así que digamos que "h" está por aquí, entonces
"x" tiene que ser igual a "h".
Una forma de pensarlo es para cualquier valor que se esté elevando al cuadrado para obtener la "y",
ahora se necesitará un valor más grande para elevar el mismo valor.
Por que se le van a restar "h" unidades a la "x" "solo para llegar al 0 "x" tiene que
solo para elevar al cuadrado un 0 "x" tiene que ser igual a "h"
si aquí quisieran elevar 1 al cuadrado, "x" solo debería ser igual a 1 pero, aquí
digamos para usar el mismo argumento, que este es el valor, es "x" igual a 1 y esto es 1 al cuadrado,
obviamente no está dibujado a escala pero esto sería 1 también
pero, ahora para elevar 1 al cuadrado no sólo necesitamos
"x" igual a 1, "x" debe ser igual a "h" más 1
debe ser una unidad mayor que "h", debe ser "h" más 1 para llegar a ese mismo punto.
Así que pueden ver el efecto de esto que en vez de elevar "x" al cuadrado si yo elevó "x" - "h" al cuadrado
desplazamos la curva a la derecha.
Así que la curva en color morado, la curva de color magenta
se verá algo así. La
desplazamos a la derecha, la desplazamos a la derecha "h" unidades.
Ahora veamos otro experimento.
Imaginemos, imaginemos que
pensemos en la curva "y"  igual a-"x" cuadrada.
Ahora sea cual sea el valor de "x" cuadrada tomaremos su negativo.
Aquí no importaba cuál "x" tomáramos, la elevabamos al cuadrado y obteníamos un valor positivo
pero, ahora tendremos siempre un valor negativo. Una vez que lo multiplicamos por-1 así que se verá
algo así, será como un espejo de "y"
igual a "x" cuadrada pero, reflejado sobre el eje horizontal.
Así que se verá más o menos así, esto es "y" igual a - "x" cuadrada.
Ahora imaginemos que la ajustamos aún más, cómo se
cómo se verá la "y" igual a
igual a - 2x cuadrada bueno, primero permítanme hacer 2 cosas ¿Cómo se vería? "y" igual a 2x cuadrada?
Primero hagamos la versión positiva, entonces "y"igual a 2x cuadrada
ahora aparte de elevar cada valor al cuadrado, lo multiplicaremos por 2
así que va a empezar a crecer más rápido, se verá como esto, será más angosta y alargada será más o menos así.
Lo que yo quiero es darles una idea, realmente no dibuje esto a escala pero, entonces
esto lo hará crecer.
Dependiendo del factor irá creciendo más rápido.
Si ahora hacemos "y" igual a - 2x cuadrada
"y" igual a -2 x cuadrada,
entonces se hará negativo más rápido, así que se verá así, será un espejo de lo que acabo de dibujar.
Entonces será una parábola, una parábola más angosta justo como ésta e igualmente
y sé que mi diagrama se está poniendo
bastante confuso pero, solo recuerden que empezamos con "y" igual a "x" cuadrada que es esta curva.
Qué pasaría si hiciéramos "y" igual a 1/2 de "x" cuadrada.
Este me estoy quedando sin colores también pero, bueno si hiciéramos "y" igual a 1/2 de 2x cuadrada,
entonces las cosas empezarían a crecer más lento, se verá igual pero, más abierta hacia arriba,
crecerá más lentamente
se verá algo algo así.
Ojalá que esto les da idea de cómo podemos ajustar las parábolas. Si por ejemplo, si por ejemplo tengo,
voy a hacerlo, voy a hacer un dibujo un poco burdo aquí para darles la idea general de lo que estamos hablando.
Entonces si es "y" igual a "x" cuadrada,
ésta es la gráfica de "y" igual a "x" cuadrada, esta es "y"  igual a "x" cuadrada. La gráfica de "y".
Voy a usar un color que no haya usado todavía, la gráfica de "y" - "k" igual a
"a" por
"x" -"h" al cuadrado se verá así.
En lugar de que el vértice esté en 0,0,
el vértice o lo más bajo, o se podría decir el punto mínimo o máximo
el punto extremo de la parábola, este punto de aquí,
sería el punto máximo de una parábola que abre hacia abajo o el punto mínimo de una que abre hacia arriba,
ese punto estará desplazado "h" hacia la derecha,
"h" hacia la derecha y "k" unidades hacia arriba, entonces el vértice estará por aquí,
y va a estar escalado por "a", si "a" es mayor que,
si "a" es igual a 1 se verá igual, tendrá la misma abertura, tendrá la misma
abertura, si "a" es igual a 1 si es mayor que 1
será más angosta algo así pero, si "a" es menor que 1 pero mayor que 0
tendrá una abertura más ancha como esto. Ahora si "a" es
exactamente 0 se convierte en una línea recta y si "a" es negativo pero menor que -1,
tendrá una amplia abertura, algo así más bien, debí decir si es mayor que -1.
Si está entre 0 y -1 tendrá una amplia abertura como esta.
En 1 negativo se verá como un reflejo de nuestra
curva original y por último, si "a" es menor que -1 o sea más negativo,
entonces será una parábola más angosta que se verá como ésta,
entonces
espero que eso les de una buena idea de cómo ajustar y desplazar parábolas.